Hello youtube's lovers friends this is
Gunjan here and today I am going to show you some
of the nice traps exist against the
English opening now compared to all other openings
the white English opening has the
least number of traps exist for the
black and that is  Why It's Very
Popular To All Levels Of Chess Now If You Do
n't Have Any Systems Against The English
Opening Then You Should Certainly Try Out The
System What I'm Going To Recommend Today Here I
Propose You Start With The Move e5
And After Very  National Looking Knight to c3 Here comes
the surprise to your opponent with this move
bishop to b4 So the idea of ​​bishop
to b4 is very simple Black wants to
capture the knight and give white a double pawn and the
theory is pretty much similar to the sisin
Rojo's Lie of White So if your opponent is allowing you to
capture that knight I strongly recommend Black's knight
put the knight on f6 so that means if White wishes
White can avoid the
double pawn and attack his loose bishop with this move which
is knight to d5.  And here again black
has a few replies black bishop can go
to c5 and bishop can go back to e7 but the move I
like most is bishop to c5 and here
the tactical battle will be joined with white now
if your opponent is like  A classical
English player who is more used to playing four
knights in English then he would like to
play this move which is knight t f3 but before
looking at what happens if your opponent plays some other
English moves so for example if
your opponent plays moves like
g3 then a very simple but very effective
plan of the black goes like this so black
will start with knight to c6 followed by d6
then f5 and then after knight to f6 castling
on the king side
you can see by the arrow black has a slow
burning  Attack on the white king side and this
is very effective and easy to understand
plan so the main move here will be knight to f3 but after knight
to f3 black will definitely go
with e4 so attacking the loose knight now most
of the white players one  Meet this position they
respond with a classical approach when
d4 counter attacking the black bishop and
here paradoxically black will play bishop
to at Have you ever imagine that none of your
pieces comes out into the board and still you are
creating a trap that sounds like
Impossible Right But That Is Exactly The
Situation Is Over Here Because The Law Of The
Black Piece Has Been Developed And Still Black
Has
Created This Trap So When The First
Time I See This Position I Thought
On Con White Play Bishop To f4 Attacking The Lu
c7  Pun well ago this give a stunning
trappist so uptal now der morn 10 people
fal to this tra and the trap ras like this so yer
black just beh lak he hain this and
catch the night and after night to c7 black will play
stunning reply vi e  Queen Cross c7 and
After Very Nervous Bishop Cross c7 Here Comes
The Whole Idea Is the Bishop to be in Check and the Only
Way to Block the Check Is Putting the
Queen in Between After Words Black Will
Simply Snap Off the Queen and After King
Text  You can see black is clearly emerging
with the piece up so that one of the knight's traps
exists in this line and you should always
look out for this trap but instead of bishop
b4 What will happen if white will move the knight
please note here white  Knight cannot go to the
e5 If White's knight goes to the e5 then
very simple will be d6 and that knight is trapped so
as I highlighted by the arrows over here knight can go only
three critical squares but
against each the plan of black is very
Simple so for example if white plays lets say very good
looking national move for the
white is knight to g1 but after vice black can
reply with the c6 and after knight to c3
and d5 it looks like a french defense but
in reverse
color that means black  Has Gained a Tempo Even
If You Do Not Understand How the Hell on Earth
Black is a Move Ahead Let's count the
number of moves Black and the White place so
for example Black has played this bishop to
first of all b4 then it goes back  to c5 and then it goes
back to f8 so that means
black has lost three tame pieces otherwise if you
compare it to the white white this knight goes to the
f3 then again it goes back to the g1 and this
knight of the white goes to the  d5 and again it goes
back to the c3 so that means white has lost four tempo compared
to the black the tempo
and that's why
defense with a tempo down can't be
good so that's one of the great ideas of this
opening now in one of my  Game instead of
d4 one of my opponent which was much higher
rated around 2200 plus he decided to
play this move which is knight to g5 and at
first sight it looks like white has
given up the piece so if the queen captures this knight then
the very  The simple reply of white is
knight cross c7 and fo king king and rook
so
datchy force but here comes the other nasty
traps for black black will play amazing move which
is e3 no matter how
white capture leads to a piece
down or the mate  So for
example let's start with the west one
first so if knight captures e3 then the very
simple e queen captures knight and black i
emerge vi piece up if a cross
e3 then black can play this m vi e c6 so now
you can see right now  Two pcs are
hanging so the only logical way to come out from this
tack is to play knight to e4 but after very
simple queen to h4 check white will lose a
piece so that is f crosses e3 and if now
d crosses e3 then again black can
Responding with c6 so again the two pieces are
hanging and this time very natural looking move
knight to e4 can be successfully made with
c cross d5 and after knight cross c5 this
time black will gain a knight from the
different side of the board so this time  Black
will give a check from queen to a5 and again
Black will emerge with a piece up so that means that pun
is ante cable but how many of your
opponent can see that variation It's unlike The
only good logical reply by White which
is d4 played  By your opponent then I show you
one of the game which will give you an idea how you can handle this
position The game which I am going to show you
is between lot and Kamnik and here
Kamnik continue with e cross
f2 and after kin cross f2  Black
plays bishop to e7 so attacking the knight and after knight
cross e7 queen cross e7 White
responded with the e4 please note if you
play h6 and after knight to f3 if you grab a pawn then
you will surrender the initiative to
White so please do  Don't do that because white can
simply reply with bishop to d3 and
after queen to c6 white can give this check and after
knight to e7 and bishop to f4 the lad
white is a pun down white has a tre mendes
initiative and pc streams out very very quickly
And if needed white king can go
back so please do not play a6 at this
position so instead of this you can play a move which has been
played by the comenik so
here you should continue with the d6 and after
bishop to d3 here comely continues with  The
knight to c6 attacking the pawn his opponent responded with
bishop to c2 but after the normal
developing move the knight to f6 White plays rook
to e1 Here Kamnik completed his last
piece development with bishop to g4 and his
queen to d3 Kamnik simply replied with the knight.
to d7 so you can see these three guys are
controlling the e5 and black has a choice which
side he wants to castle and black has a
very wonderful position to play so I hope you l and
enjoy the traps which I have shown
today please try out  In Your Own Game Even Do
Some of the Trap Done Work You Will Obtain a Very
Nice Position to Play Please Feel Free
to Comment and I'll Meet You Soon By